in its current state rust is very much
an alpha it's crude rough around the
edges and full of bugs in serious need
of fixing but it also happens to be a
wildly entertaining sandbox full of
emergent gameplay and unpredictable
player interactions okay I'll kill him
for it oh you're gonna you guys fight to
the death the winner gets the pickaxe
okay now go fight I want blood rust is
more framework than finished product
right now but it's absolutely brimming
with potential the world of rust is an
unforgiving one with no clear goal other
than survival threats to your existence
come in the form of wild animals zombies
and scariest of all other players but
the most immediate danger when you first
begin is hunger armed with a little more
than a rock you'll likely find yourself
chasing deer and wild boar across
rolling valleys and dense forests in a
desperate quest to fill your stomach but
use that rock to smash at trees and
large boulders and you can craft
yourself a stone hatchet making the task
of hunting far more manageable and not
to mention elegant indeed crafting is a
big focus and rust is something that
plays a very large role in the game's
potential for open-ended entertainment
by collecting wood and smelting or you
can construct everything from a basic
shed to a sprawling compound fortified
with spikes and watchtowers these
buildings are highly modular allowing
you to build a window here and a
stairway there in order to create
something that suits your own personal
needs but you can also craft weapons and
armor bows to hunt wild animals guns to
hunt enemy players or hazmat gear to
venture into irradiated towns where you
might lock into finding preassembled
items it's a robust system but it's also
clumsy and in need of refinement
boulders and wood piles are the most
efficient places to gather resources but
snatched up like precious diamonds in
any server with a remotely decent player
population and take ages to respond once
they've been claimed you can spend hours
wandering through the game's sprawling
map and return to your base with hardly
anything to show for it you you my
friend you there in this field jumping
up and down I'd like to talk to you how
are you doing
stoned Lotus what's up you don't have a
microphone to you
this is awkward this is very awkward I'm
gonna back away now beyond that resource
gathering is riddled with logical
oddities like the way you gather cloth
and chicken meat from a dead bear and
the inventory system is clunky at best
but with any luck those issues will be
ironed out in future patches because
what's in place right now has the
potential to be a truly special open
world adventure at any given moment in
rust you might wander into a group of
players and you're not really sure
whether it's a group of bandits or
people who might be your new best
friends you can try to run away from
people who are trying to kill you or you
can team up to take down a bear together
whether they want you to or not this
guys having bear troubles don't worry I
know a good trick I know a good trick
it's to smash it with a rock alright I
know it's way too bot it's but it's the
butt of the bear rust is a lot like a
lookingglass that peers into the human
psyche and for better or worse it's a
whole lot of fun in its unpredictability
for a game with no narrative it's
capable of generating one wonderful and
bizarre story after the next and it's
one that's constantly getting better the
development team at facepunch studios
has already implemented substantial
improvements since rust went on sale
last month including the recent edition
of door sharing that makes communal
bases even more viable as well as
technical improvements such as reduced
lag on servers with an especially taxing
load of player made buildings at $20
rust requires a real willingness to
forgive its technical shortcomings in
order to experience the emergent
gameplay that makes it such a promising
entry in the survive
genre but it's a game that continues to
improve with each passing update and the
potential that lies beneath those flaws
becomes even easier to see whether or
not you choose to buy it now rust is
certainly a game to keep an eye on you
want the pickaxe yeah alright here it is
you have to kill me with it though
that's part of the deal okay make it
quick but not too quick and now I die